[Music]
welcome back to science clique
today the mathematics of general
relativity
part two space time velocity
we are now able to describe the position
of the apple through two coordinates on
the grid
[Music]
as we saw we interpret the world line as
a movement
while proper time goes by the
coordinates of the apple which describe
its position
evolve they depend on proper time and it
is therefore
interesting to define the notion of
velocity
the velocity of the apple in space-time
is an arrow
a vector tangent to its trajectory whose
orientation
follows its movement the length of this
arrow encodes the speed of the movement
this speed is the same everywhere
because the intervals are regularly
spaced along the world line
for a given proper time the apple always
travels the same distance
[Music]
more generally all objects in the
universe move with exactly the same
speed
it is a universal constant which we call
the speed of light
denoted by the letter c
therefore we can write our very first
equation which states that the length of
the velocity
its norm is always equal to the speed of
light
when using coherent units for example if
we measure time in seconds
and distances in light seconds the speed
of light
is precisely one this simply means that
time is a measure of distance the proper
time of an object simply measures the
distance
travelled through space-time
for each second of proper time the apple
travels one light second
through space time
[Music]
we now want to describe velocity using
our coordinates
starting from the apple we draw two
arrows on the grid that represent the
directions and amplitudes of each
coordinate
these arrows are called basis vectors we
will denote them
e0 and e1 given the coordinates they
respectively describe
with these two basis vectors we can
decompose the velocity
as a sum here for example
two blue arrows and one red arrow
the numbers two and one are called the
components
of the vector the value of a component
indicates the rate at which the
corresponding coordinate increases
in a way we measure the rate at which
the apple moves along
each of the two coordinates as proper
time goes by
more generally we can write the velocity
vector as the sum of its components
multiplied by the basis vectors
in mathematical expressions in general
relativity
it often happens that a same term is
summed over
all coordinates one by one
for example in the previous equation we
wrote the vector as the sum of each
component
multiplied by each basis vector
to compactify this expression we can
summarize the whole sum by writing only
one of these terms
and replacing the numbers which
designate the coordinates by a greek
letter
for example alpha which goes through
each coordinate one by one
this is the einstein notation when a
greek letter is repeated twice
once up and once down it actually stands
for a sum
in which this greek letter is replaced
by each coordinate
one by one
let's illustrate this concept of
space-time velocity using a concrete
example
we imagine a satellite in a circular
orbit around the earth
when viewed from a distant position the
movement of the satellite can be
described using two coordinates
time that we measure on our clock t
and an angle phi which describes the
position of the satellite around the
planet
[Music]
looking at its world line we can plot
the velocity of the satellite
at each point this vector can then be
decomposed with our two coordinates
the first component gives us its
temporal speed
it is the rate at which our time passes
compared to the satellite's proper time
if this value is 2 for example this
means that for every second that passes
for the satellite
two seconds will have passed for us
[Music]
the second component represents its
angular speed
it is the rate at which the angle formed
by the satellite around the earth
increases
if its value is 10 degrees per second
this means that for each second of
proper time
the satellite moves 10 degrees around
the planet
the first equation we obtained before
allows us to say that the length of the
vector is
always the same this is the speed of
light
at a glance one might think that we can
use the pythagorean theorem
to calculate the length of the velocity
given its components
but it is crucial to understand that the
coordinates do not represent
real distances their values and their
rate of change are arbitrary numbers
which do not have real physical
significance for example
the angle formed by these two satellites
increases at the same rate
their velocities have the same angular
component but it's easy to see that it
doesn't mean they have the same speed
the farthest satellite moves faster even
though its vector has the same component
in the next videos we will see how to
solve this problem
how to get a real measure of physical
distances and speed from components
building a new version of the
pythagorean theorem
more general which works in space-time
regardless of which grid we use
[Music]
you